OK.
Donald Trump had a completely propagandistic
1984 style town hall yesterday.
He took questions from Americans via video
while sitting at the Lincoln Memorial yesterday.
We believe that it was Donald Trump who had
selected the Lincoln Memorial as the location.
But then during this event, Donald Trump said,
oh, no, you guys told the Fort, you guys being
Fox News, you guys told us you wanted it.
At the Lincoln Memorial, the two Fox hosts,
Bret Bear and Martha MacCallum, visibly confused
about.
Wait a second.
I thought we were here because you wanted
us here.
Doesn't even matter.
That's only the tip of the iceberg.
My friends, because it was an absolute and
complete nightmare now because we're doing
fewer and fewer of the briefings.
I do think it's important to bring you a sense
of what the president is communicating and
in relation to our segment earlier today on
whether the United States is a failed state
of sorts.
Last night's town hall was more than illuminating
in that sense.
Now, first of all, Donald Trump came in absolutely
shot out of a cannon like he was on some kind
of upper.
And we've talked about this before.
Trump visibly very sweaty, sniffing, repeating
himself more than usual, clenching his jaw,
unable to sit still.
And, you know, we know about these two versions
of Trump.
You've got upper Trump and then you've got
downor Trump, as I like to call them, something
very strange seems to continue with Donald
Trump along those lines.
It's tough to analyze and we may never know
the full scope of that.
Let's put this sort of appearance aside and
focus on the content.
What we can more easily analyze was the absolutely
debased and abominable things that Donald
Trump said, along with the complete and total
lack of truth in almost every single answer
that Donald Trump gave.
It would be hard to do a more dishonest town
hall.
He also barely answered any of the questions
in any anything what we would call direct
sense.
But as we go through this, I want to frame
it for you upfront.
His supporters loved it.
Before we go into the clips, understand that
however you see Donald Trump as a hopefully
rational, sensible thinking person who watches
or listens to the David Pakman show what you
see in these upcoming clips.
His followers loved and saw as strong Trump
unwilling to be bullied and pushed around
competent Trump dealing with everything perfectly.
That's a really scary reality that we have
to come to terms with.
Let's get into it.
Donald Trump often mentions the 1918 flu.
He often calls it the 1917 flu.
This was a pandemic from about 100 years ago.
It was a late 1918 through early summer of
1919.
It affected infected, rather, it's believed
about 500 million.
The death rate could have been the death toll
could have been anywhere from 17 million.
You hear 50 million.
You sometimes hear 100 million based on the
numbers you look at.
Trump wildly claims without evidence that
the 19 17 flu ended World War 1 prematurely.
Check this out.
Right.
You remember the Spanish flu.
So much has been written about it.
Now, of course, it's Stardust, everybody that
writes a book about the Spanish flu, 1917,
it killed between 100 and I guess 50 to 100
million people.
It probably ended the First World War because
the soldiers were all getting sick.
Now, this is not true.
It's simply not true.
The war sort of formally ended with the Treaty
of Vici in June of 1919.
But fighting had mostly died down seven months
prior to that.
There's no question that there were service
members around the world infected with the
flu.
But this is a crazy thing for Donald Trump
to say.
No pushback whatsoever from Martha MacCallum
and Bret Bayer not to defend them, but almost
everything Trump said on this issue was false.
So there was a sort of Gish Gallop effect
going on.
Look that term up if you're not familiar with
it.
Trump was asked a question about how he was
supposedly getting intelligence on the virus
really early and he ignored it.
And Donald Trump.
Claimed that he wasn't told that the virus
might be a thing until January 23rd.
I'm going to play the clip for you.
Now, remember, we had our first case on January
20th that we know of.
We now know it was obviously far earlier because
of when the first death happened.
But there are two options here.
When Trump says he was first told this could
be a thing on January 23rd.
Neither is good.
I'll tell them to you after we watched the
clip, because I did the right thing.
I saved hundreds of thousands of lives.
OK.
She's asking me the question about intelligence.
I have the head of the intelligence agencies
here today.
And here's the exact thing.
And we have it.
It's going to be released tomorrow or the
next day.
But I released today on January 23rd.
I was told that there could be a virus coming
in, but it was of no real import.
In other words, it wasn't all we got to do
some we got to do something.
So understand.
Trump says he was told January 23 the virus
might come in.
We had our first case three days earlier.
OK.
We had our first case on January 20th.
South Korea had its first case right around
the same time as we did within hours of our
first case.
They by January 23rd, were already developing
a test and setting up ways to contact, trace
and isolate people.
And Trump is now claiming he was first told
this could be coming in three days after the
first case.
Now, there's two options here.
One is Trump is just lying.
And I believe Trump is lying now.
He's met his brain, may have turned to mayonnaise,
and he may not recall that he was being briefed
about this in early January.
There are reports about briefings in December.
There are now some reports which we have not
yet fully corroborated that suggest in late
November this was already being discussed.
So Trump could just be lying and saying, I
didn't even really hear about this as a serious
thing until three days after the first case.
That is probably a lie.
If it's true, it's outrageous that Trump was
not seriously warned until three days after
the first case.
It goes against every bit of reporting we
have.
I believe Trump is lying or has completely
lost his memory.
Neither is good.
Continuing with this disgusting town hall,
Donald Trump claims that he has been treated,
that he he has been treated worse than Abraham
Lincoln.
And hilariously, the person asking the question
actually said, why do you sometimes ramble
without asking questions that are asked of
you by the press?
Here is part of Donald Trump's answer.
The question I have is about your manner of
presentation.
Why do you use descriptive words that could
be classified as bullying?
Why do not directly answer the questions asked
by the press, but instead speak of past successes
in January?
USA need you, please.
Like all those behaviors that are turning
people away from you.
Please hold on to your wonderful accurate.
Is that make you our great leader and let
go of other characteristics that do not serve
you?
I like a croissant and I'm not sure, but I
think I like that question.
I appreciate and I appreciate the prayers
too very much.
Look, I am greeted with a hostile press, the
likes of which no president has ever seen.
The closest would be that gentleman right
up there.
They always said Lincoln.
Nobody got treated worse than Lincoln.
I believe I am treated worse.
Now, of course, Abraham Lincoln was assassinated.
OK. Trump is talking about being treated worse
by the press than Lincoln.
But again, Trump's delusions, delusions of
grandeur treated worse than anyone, including
Lincoln, because sometimes the press asks
real questions and he never answers them.
And they have to ask again.
Now, on the death toll, this is really important
and it's actually tragic.
Donald Trump is very casually moving the goalposts
for close to a month.
Donald Trump has been saying we're going to
have 60000 deaths thanks to me.
Could have had 1.5 million.
We could've had 2.2 million.
But thanks to me, our death toll is going
to be only 60000.
That ship has sailed.
We now we're already at almost 70000 deaths
in the United States.
So Trump has very smoothly talked about.
Listen, we could lose 80 or 90 thousand and
that would be terrible.
Moving the goalposts.
Take a look.
That's one of the reasons we're successful.
That's one of the if you call losing 80 or
90 thousand people successful.
But it's one of the reasons that we're not
at that high end of the plane as opposed to
the low end of that number has changed.
Mr. President, you said it's going up the.
I used to say 65000.
And now I'm saying 80 or 90.
And it goes up and it goes up rapidly.
But it's still going to be no matter how you
look at it.
At the very lower end of the plane, if we
did the shutdown.
Now, this was always the plan, say some insanely
high number.
That would only happen if he literally did
nothing and then say he gets credit for it
being less.
Understand a couple of different things.
This 1.5 million, 2.2 million Trump for the
first time now floating 2.5 million, that
may have been if he literally did nothing.
No president could realistically do nothing.
So it's an outrageous bar to set to even compare
to.
But the real dishonesty is that in the last
48 hours, Trump has increased his expect the
death toll by 50 percent from 60000 to 90000.
And the way things are going, it could easily
be a hundred thousand before we know it.
But Trump is immune from criticism because,
again, without him, it would have been 2 million.
He's now for the first time, floated 2.5 million
if he did nothing.
That's a higher number than he's ever mentioned
before.
This is mere politics for Donald Trump.
It's not lives.
And one just strange moment during yesterday's
town hall was again.
It was a very hopped up Trump who seemed to
be clenching and sweating and visibly on some.
He was upper Trump.
I don't want to say what he was on, if anything,
but he was upper Trump.
He said that he was asked for Schwab's Schwab's
by a governor.
This is just too funny.
We had one Governor Inslee who's always wanting
something.
And frankly, he didn't do a very good job
in nursing homes, as far as I'm concerned,
state of Washington.
And he said, we need swaps.
I said, why don't you get them yourself?
But if you can't, we'll get him.
So drops a totally lie riddled propaganda
event.
A few other notes.
Donald Trump said Joe Biden wrote him a letter
of apology.
That's just not true.
Trump once again started talking about hydroxy
chloroquine and told multiple lies about its
efficacy.
And Trump continues to say that China is paying
for tariffs.
I want to take a moment just to explain that
I need everybody in my audience to understand
this.
And I think most of you do.
Trump still doesn't understand how tariffs
work.
Trump continues to insist we're punishing
China by putting tariffs on them, which they
are paying us.
And sometimes he says, it's like a tax on
China.
Please understand that American companies
play the tariff, pay the tariffs.
I know I've said this before.
I have to keep repeating it because Trump
seems to still not understand.
If China sells steel for a thousand bucks
a rod.
OK.
Doesn't matter.
Whatever amount, a thousand bucks is a ton.
And we put a tariff on China.
China still sells that steel for a thousand
bucks a ton.
But if there's a 15 percent tariff on it,
when an American company buys it, the American
company pays China a thousand bucks and they
pay the government one hundred and fifty more
dollars.
American companies pay the tariffs.
Now, if you believe that this trade war would
work, China could be forced to lower their
price and accept a lower price because of
the tariff that American companies are buying.
It's not happening.
Trump still doesn't understand how tariffs
work.
We are seeing the active and willful dissemination
of weaponized propaganda.
But the saddest thing is that his followers
love it and they see this as a strong performance.
We have one option and it's to remove Trump
in November.
I hope you'll help me do that.